problema número 15 si el triángulo abc y
el triángulo x ez son dos triángulos
tales que aquí nos dan una igualdad de
razones déjame dibujar los triángulos
para ir siguiendo lo que nos dicen
entonces por aquí voy a dibujar el
triángulo abc abc y por acá voy a poner
el x iceta y al final hay que ver que
son semejantes entonces los voy a
dibujar más o menos semejantes
más o menos algo así algo así
vale entonces este se llama el triángulo
a b c este va a ser el triángulo x y z c
está muy bien sigo leyendo entonces si
el triángulo abc y el triángulo x y z
son dos triángulos tales que ave entre
xy la razón deja la marco ave entre xy
es la misma que la razón bc / zeta
entonces vece bc / zeta 3 ez cuál de las
siguientes opciones sería suficiente
para probar que los triángulos son
semejantes queremos ver que los
triángulos de an semejantes es decir
queremos ver o bien que los tres ángulos
correspondientes son iguales o bien
queremos ver que la razón entre lados
correspondientes es la misma para cada
una de las tres parejas de lados
correspondientes vale bueno entonces
cómo podemos hacer para ver esto ya
tenemos una igualdad verdad ya tenemos
una igualdad de razones este entre este
igual es igual a este entre este de acá
antes de ver las opciones vamos a pensar
un poco tan solo con eso será suficiente
pues yo digo que no por ejemplo
pudiéramos tener dos triángulos así a lo
mejor tenemos aquí está uno de los lados
este es uno de los lados y el
correspondiente mide la mitad y puede
ser que tengamos otro de los lados algo
así y que el correspondiente también
mida la mitad
como la mitad más o menos como algo así
pero estos dos triángulos
definitivamente no son semejantes de
este triángulo en la que arribita no es
semejante al de aquí abajo porque pues a
simple vista se ve que no tienen los
mismos ángulos vaya este segmento lo
puedo ir girando para donde quiera y
entonces tenemos dos triángulos en los
cuales esta razón es la razón de este
entre este es igual a la de este entre
este pero son triángulos que no son
semejantes entonces hay que pedir algo
más y si nos acordamos un poco de
nuestras clases de geometría esa cosa
que tenemos que pedir para que de
adeveras sean semejantes es la igualdad
del ángulo entre esas parejas de lados
que ya vimos que tienen la misma
proporción es decir en el caso de los de
aquí arriba lo que tendríamos que pedir
es que el ángulo en b sea congruente al
ángulo en que el ángulo entre las
parejas de lados que sabemos que son
proporcionales debe de ser congruente
vale bueno entonces tenemos que pedir
eso de ahí vamos a ver si encontramos
eso en las opciones el ángulo a
congruente al ángulo en x ahorita
pensamos está y el ángulo en b
congruente al ángulo
si eso es justo lo que acabo de decir
que el ángulo de enmedio que el ángulo
en medio
congruente muy bien a ver vamos a pensar
tanto en la opción a esa se ve más o
menos tentadora entonces dice que el
ángulo en a sea congruente al ángulo en
x creo que en este caso de acá pedir eso
sí es suficiente y tiene que ver con que
ve ese es el lado más largo del
triángulo a bs pero quién sabe a lo
mejor éste no está y éste esa y este c y
a lo mejor estos dos también están
cambiados o sea más bien déjame
explicarte a qué me refiero viendo esta
de acá la c la opción c sea imagínate
que sabemos que el ángulo en c el ángulo
en c es congruente al ángulo en zeta
vale entonces yo digo que esta igualdad
de ángulos no es suficiente para mostrar
que los dos triángulos son semejantes
porque por ejemplo a lo mejor pudiéramos
tener que el punto x no está acá si no
está de este lado del lado donde se hace
un triángulo isósceles de esta forma
este mide lo mismo que éste y fíjate que
que tendríamos tendríamos que haber
entre y x este es un nuevo punto x sería
igual abc entre zeta tendríamos que el
ángulo en c es congruente al ángulo en
zeta
pero los triángulos xz y abc
definitivamente no son semejantes
entonces aquí hay un problema verdad o
sea como como ave es es un lado
intermedio es un lado chiquito entonces
puede ser que este ángulo sea congruente
a éste pero los triángulos no queden
semejantes entonces ésta no sería
suficiente y si intercambiamos con c y
equis con zeta entonces sería un ejemplo
para ver que está de acá no es
suficiente ya nada más tendríamos que
analizar la d pero la de seve como que
medio rara verdad pide la igualdad del
ángulo x con el ángulo y el ángulo en x
con el ángulo n pero la igualdad de esos
dos de esos dos ángulos pues no nos dice
gran cosa solo nos dice que quise sietes
isósceles pero pues igual este ángulo
puede irse moviendo y que suceda una
situación como la de aquí abajo entonces
la opción de tampoco nos permite
concluir que sean triángulos semejantes
y por lo tanto la respuesta es ve muy
bien déjame pasar aquí abajo
para resolver el siguiente problema
problema número problema número 16 voy a
agarrar este color azul el problema
número 16 dice lo siguiente dice en el
paralelogramo fchi vamos a dibujarlo
entonces por ahí tengo un lado por aquí
tengo otro lado que tiene que ser
paralelo a este de acá algo de ese
estilo
más o menos ese es un paralelogramo muy
decente entonces en el paralelogramo f g
h y h y las diagonales se dibujan las
diagonales y g efe h
y fh se dibujan y se intersectan en el
punto m se intersectan en el punto m va
entonces esta es paralela a esta de acá
esta es paralela a esta de acá
cuál de los siguientes enunciados debe
ser cierto debe ser cierto sea siempre
es cierto a ver
el triángulo fg y debe ser o tus ángulo
el triángulo efe y debe ser obtusa
ángulo pues aquí si me quedo tus ángulo
verdad si parece ser que fg y es un
triángulo o tus ángulo pero esto será
siempre es cierto siempre es cierto pues
yo digo que no porque a lo mejor pude
haber dibujado el paralelogramo al revés
por ejemplo a ver si me sale aquí
rápidamente un contraejemplo algo de
este estilo aquí tenemos esta diagonal
esta diagonal sin esta quedó bien fea
allí está entonces a lo mejor porque
tenemos la libertad de dibujar cualquier
paralelogramo verdad a lo mejor dibuje
este de acá
efe je je je y ii y en este
paralelogramo el triángulo fg y que es
este que voy a marcar en naranja pues
definitivamente no es obtusa ángulo
verdad este de aquí no eso tus ángulo
entonces ya encontré un paralelogramo
paralelogramo en el cual fg y no esos
ángulo y por lo tanto la opción es
incorrecta de esto de aquí no siempre es
cierto
vamos a ver qué pasa con la opción b el
triángulo h
debe ser agudo ángulo el triángulo h y g
debe ser apunta nulo pues no aquí tengo
un paralelogramo hecho y derecho y en
ese paralelogramo podemos tomar el
triángulo ahí ya quedó claro el
triángulo h
que sería este de acá y es el no está
cut ángulo porque el ángulo en h es
mayor a 90 grados entonces este de acá
este de acá es un contraejemplo para
entonces estar acá tampoco es cierto si
el triángulo fmg debe ser congruente al
triángulo hm g efe cmg lo voy a pintar
con color rojo
entonces el f m
smg
fmg debe ser congruente al triángulo h m
g al h m g estoy acá
pues no estoy ahí tampoco tiene que ser
forzosamente cierto verdad observa que
aquí pues sí o sea en efecto este lado
es congruente a sí mismo y las
diagonales de un paralelogramo se cortan
a la mitad entonces esto es congruente a
éste pero para que sean congruentes
deben de tener iguales los tres lados y
este lado no tiene por qué ser igual a
este este lado puede ser larguísimo
larguísimo y este medir pues está esta
longitud corta y entonces estos dos no
necesariamente tienen que ser
congruentes y por lo tanto estos dos
triángulos no son congruentes entonces
la opción se tampoco se vale así que me
imagino que la respuesta debe debe ser d
pero vamos a ver si podemos demostrarlo
entonces vamos a marcar d vamos a marcar
de y de dice el triángulo gm h debe ser
congruente al triángulo imf voy a
trabajar con el de aquí abajo que tiene
un poco más de espacio
entonces el eje m estoy aquí es el m
el gm h
gm h queremos que sea congruente al imf
y m efe ah pues eso de ahí si se ve que
son se ve que son congruentes pero vamos
a probarlo te dejo de tarea para que lo
pienses utilizando algunos criterios de
congruencia ver que en un paralelogramo
los lados opuestos son congruentes
entonces tenemos que efe no solo es
paralelo a gh como segmento sino que
además miden lo mismo entonces déjame
marcar este de aquí este de aquí es
congruente a este de acá además como efe
gh son paralelas entonces gies una
transversal y el ángulo g
efe es el correspondiente al y gh
de esta forma tenemos que este ángulo
este ángulo es congruente a este de acá
y estoy acá y utilizando el mismo
argumento con la transversal
fh tenemos que este ángulo
este ángulo creo que más que
correspondiente se dice que es alterno
interno con este de acá es alterno
interno con este de acá y por lo tanto
son congruentes y bueno si quieres este
ángulo que le voy a poner tres marquitas
es congruente con este de acá porque son
ángulos opuestos por el vértice entonces
estos dos triángulos definitivamente son
semejantes tienen sus dos ángulos sus
dos ángulos congruentes sus tres ángulos
este con este este con este y estos dos
pero además tienen el segmento f igual
al segmento gh y por lo tanto tienen dos
lados congruentes y de ahí esos dos
triángulos son congruentes si quieres
ser un poco más formal
podemos decir que aquí utilizamos el
criterio ángulo lado ángulo de
congruencia entonces tenemos que el
triángulo f&m lo vamos a utilizar las
letras que nos ponen acá el triángulo
gmh es congruente al triángulo imf
y mf por criterio criterio
ángulo lado ángulo de congruencia muy
bien vamos a dejarle hasta aquí nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo para
resolver más problemas